sear school is a school that the
military puts on for basically anybody
who could potentially be captured Pilots
for sure cuz they eject an enemy
territory you're going to get captured
and it stands for survival evasion
resistance and escape this is after SEAL
training and sear school was the worst
imagine just like being put in like
highly uncomfortable stress positions
that you can't quite stand up you can't
quite sit you can't quite lean over it's
a little bit too warm and then like sit
in a circle on the hardwood floor which
seems like nothing oh just sit on the
ground right but for like 18 hours don't
move they bring in someone who has been
a very real p and we had this guy that
was kept during the Vietnam war who
spent like a year in captivity go and
and they will emulate what they've been
through he just told us what he went
through every torture technique you can
imagine all his friends were killed and
he was the last one but he's like so
positive he's like come on guys take
this training seriously you can do it
can I also ask how he was able to
survive captivity I think he was there
till like the area was liberated he's a
tough dude yeah he like lasted wow